We have a business proposition for you.
I mean it's the worst fake crying you've ever seen.
She's just using the technique. The what?
The technique.
Holy sh- *Clears Voice*
Amanda this is my stepdad Mark.
How long are you here Amanda?
My mom's gonna pick me up around midnight.
Midnight's late for us.
I'll call your mom she can come pick you up now.
She's busy. Doing what? Chemotherapy.
I don't have any feelings ever.
And that doesn't necessarily make me a bad person
Just means I have to work a little harder to be good.
I'm sending you to boarding school.
After that, you're off my payroll.
You hate him.
You despise him.
Honey, you can't go in with him like that. I'm fine.
It's not gonna have to stand here all day like a robot repeating myself.
I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine.
Every think about just killing him?
How would you?
What the hell is he even doing here?
I am providing you all with early drug experiences that you will forever cherish.
Who the hell are you?
We have a business proposition for you.
You've got a gun?
Yes, I have a gun.
You don't know where I come from.
Worcester.
Amanda. You have no idea.
I didn't think he'd bring it here.
You wanna hold it? No, thanks.
Anyway
You cannot hesitate
the only thing worse then being incompetent.
Or being unkind or being evil.
Is being indecisive
Okay.
Shall we?
What am I gonna tell my dad?
Wear a hat.
We're keeping this by the way.